la loi que là mais comme c'est patrick
hetzel
merci beaucoup monsieur président ma
question s'adresse à monsieur le premier
ministre
elle concerne la nomination du président
de l'inra en effet vous avez persisté à
vouloir nommer le directeur de cabinet
du ministre de l'agriculture privées
privilégiant ainsi une nouvelle fois le
copinage plutôt que les compétences
cette nomination pose problème à
plusieurs titres
tout d'abord la personne en question
n'est pas titulaire d'un doctorat
alors qu'aujourd'hui dans le monde
scientifique il est important qu'un
directeur d'organismes de recherche soit
titulaire d'un doctorat diplôme qui
crédibilise évidemment son sa compétence
scientifique
de plus le signal envoyé à la communauté
scientifique est détestable est
d'ailleurs un collectif très important
de scientifiques de renom a décidé
évidemment de show posées à ce processus
et ce matin même le président du conseil
scientifique de l'inra qui est le
président de la prestigieuse université
paris descartes paris 5 vient de
démissionner de sa fonction de président
du conseil scientifique
quel mépris pour la science mais il y a
encore plus grave
une telle nomination est purement et
simplement illégale
en effet un directeur de cabinet en
exercice candidat à la tête d'un
établissement public dont il assure par
ailleurs la tutelle par délégation
directe du ministre est en situation
caractérisée de conflit d'intérêts vous
commettez donc là une double faute
une faute juridique mais aussi une faute
morale et éthique
alors monsieur le premier ministre à
quand la république irréprochable dont
vous nous parler tant par ailleurs
merci la parole est à monsieur stéphane
le foll mini-jack les cultures
l'agroalimentaire et de la forêt le
président monsieur le député il vous
plaît s'il vous plaît avec écoute la
réponse vous avez allez monsieur
accueillez s'il vous plaît monsieur
accueillez vous avez été le sien le
monde ait connu la réponse que maman au
petit quand on les éduque je voudrais
pas le seul député sur la question qui
est évoqué premièrement dans l'histoire
de nombreux directeurs de cabinet ont
été nommés à la direction d'institutions
de recherche
c'est le premier point sur la question
juridique il n'y a rien qui justifie
l'argument que vous avez évoqué un haut
fonctionnaire qui a servi pendant 30 ans
la fonction publique dans le domaine de
l'agriculture at il un conflit
d'intérêts a assumé une direction d'un
établissement public
c'est faux a collé c'est un mensonge
c'est un procès que vous faites là un
homme qui est totalement injustifiée
deuxièmement nous avons changé les
règles avec la loi
avec un loi fioraso avec des lois
fioraso et oui le jeu accueillez vous
pouvez montjoire go ça ne se fait pas je
vous le rappelle avec la loi fioraso
nous avons changé les règles
il ya une commission d'experts qui s'est
réuni et qui a étudié les deux dossiers
des deux candidats experts incontestable
et qui sera transmis pour la première
fois par le secrétariat général aux
présidents des deux commissions des
assemblées qui auront à statuer sur la
candidature
voilà la transparence voilà la
république irréprochable
c'est peut-être ça qui vous gêne